hey poppy here it's Papa John and you're
listening to the h3 podcast go Ethan go
ela welcome everybody to the PewDiePie
couldn't make it today podcast actually
funny that I choked because he was
scheduled to come today even with the
coin was gonna zoom in zoom or zoom zoom
zoom he was gonna zoom in and something
happened cuz maybe cuz you were trying
to download Zune
maybe Zune wasn't connecting me or
something we have we having software
problems next week pewdiepie will be
joining us so looking for that today's
episode is sponsored by expressvpn honey
and me undies wow that yes while the
people still people are still riding or
dying for the h3 podcast and boy and i
just this is the worst opening to ever
it's gonna be a terrible episode I can
already fill up my bones actually no we
have a lot of good content we released
some stuff on Teddy fresh so new items I
actually can't pull it up so Stan is
going to be putting that most also we're
doing giveaways on Instagram so if we
follow and like our giveaway post
because we know that everyone is broke
right now so if you want some free Teddy
fresh gear that's the place to do it and
I'm just so happy to say that we have
made an h3 video it has happened
[Music]
we have made a new HD HD video The [ __ ]
subclade spider-man Elsa I'm very happy
people were happy everyone was happy
this whole week working from home and
like recording a video kind of felt like
going back in time it's kind of fun
though it was fun that's why we're only
doing one episode this week so I saw
some people saying where's the where's
the midweek episode well that's an h3
video and a spoiler alert there's
another one coming but nobody saw that
coming so you know what was even crazier
it was on trending it was number three
on trending that's just weird yeah
clearly no one is that YouTube
headquarters yeah they're there right
and you're right about that everyone
went home so that explains it but you
know ultimately the video turned out
good there's a lot of really funny stuff
in there I have to say that I'm sad I
had to cut there was a hole I had a
whole battle with YouTube I'm gonna call
him compliance because that's what it's
turned into and for example does this
thing the corona challenge were people
are licking public they're just licking
like toilet seats in particular I saw
one day of licking on the New York
subway the handrail that guy is in the
hospital by the way four credit hours
awesome well what's not awesome I always
probably spray you do that why would you
do that that's a really good question I
guess we're going to talk about it later
right we're not gonna talk about this
because I'm not allowed to show up so
but but I could tell you that I made a
really funny bit about it I can do that
there's the one thing that that really
was the craziest to me is these dudes in
some Arab countries I think they're
Persian but I don't know and they were
going to these shrines that people make
pilgrimages to and you know in Iran
there's a really bad corona outbreak and
so they're going to these shrines and
they're licking
and but they were looking them in such a
manner I was like it looks like they're
you know eating a girl out but I was
very vulgar about it but I thought it
was very funny and a whole bit about how
the shrines were orgasming and they kept
going back and they were like they were
getting crazy Heather talked about like
that and I thought it was great it was
my favorite part of the video actually
but I had to cut it mm-hmm I guess it
was very vulgar but that but the reason
that they had me cut it is because they
think that showing these challenges will
encourage more people to do it even
though I'm obviously lampooning them but
okay
and that's YouTube for you I see you
keep looking at my sweater do you want
to say anything I mean I guess yeah
that's what as bad as I have nothing bad
to say about this is my quarantine
outfit
Elton Klein I think we should embrace
the quarantine and just stressful crazy
you saying you wouldn't wear that out in
public I guess I wouldn't just wear it
on a Friday at 2:00 p.m.
I'd be whoa when is the appropriate time
you are like is it a nice where would
you go why that's a dinner what's the
occasion Bar Mitzvah bar it's probably a
mom oh is this a dress-up with someone
with bad taste yeah see I see this as
casual fun okay I would love to see
Teddy fresh garment using yeah sequin
yeah I know something it's a quaint I
don't know but anyway if you haven't
seen it there's a new HD video out that
we're all just so excited over you know
a lot of people make more commenting the
most on this crazy mother effing
creature who was saying that he was
healing people of the coronavirus he had
the television screen Kenneth Copeland
and he people were saying that he's just
like the evilest looking mother effort
it really is he just needs a little
manners since where he goes yeah
just flip it on you real fast to be like
yeah also that there was we've actually
watched happiness before
it's mine it's mine it looks like a
white thank you and praise alright he
does look like a look
turn it up yeah and I praise you that
I'm well and hold
according to looks like you're dipped is
him baffling to us all that's weird that
I'm so it could finger baby and I'm just
ready at any time that's what's so scary
right now I I have to tell you the
people that are really spreading this
stuff and being irresponsible are well
young kids that are just dumb and
ignorant but then there's there's really
just a lot of I don't want to be super
offensive here but let's not be okay
good point there's just a lot of
ignorant people yeah it's a certain
symmetry but it's amplified by these
religious people too well you know that
the virus this week has gotten bad well
this guy doesn't represent most normal
religious people
no no but a lot of people are down with
this and I've been seeing more and more
footage of preachers being like I refuse
to cancel service I'm gonna have a
thousand people in my pew Easter Sunday
work the pews are gonna be full if these
people all go out on Easter to
congregate thousands of them I mean
there's gonna be yeah the rate of spread
in this virus isn't saying there's gonna
be an unimaginable outbreak from that
and you know the places where it's
growing the most now this week was funny
enough Florida Louisiana they had Mardi
Gras after their national emergency was
was declared and now Louisiana is like
one of the becoming the epicenter simha
Florida mm-hmm so
these kinds of people are I don't know
what people are thinking I'm just
thinking to myself I don't want to leave
the house I don't know because they
don't get it they don't yeah it's too
far away they need to wait until they
know somebody who's died or is in the
hospital until they realize it's
everyone they panic yeah and then they
panic but they they won't look they
won't listen to reason until it slaps
him in the face because they they can't
fathom it and that's why most people
need to listen to Spring Breakers we
made fun of in our video they're like it
ain't that bad you know the it's
overstated we're all out here we're fine
you know they don't get it once someone
we know for example who was naysaying he
thought we were all over overreacting
and now he knows somebody close to him
who died of Corona and now all of a
sudden he's like the most paranoid
person of all even listen but now it's
starting to affect us this is kind of
crazy thing but Mike my grandpa who's 94
years old in Las Vegas he lives in a
assisted living home he's in the
hospital right now with double pneumonia
and they think he's gonna die and they
think he has coronavirus he had a flu
and he had trouble breathing so they
brought him to the hospital and he has
pneumonia in both lungs and what's
create like okay so being close to the
situation makes me realize a few things
that I didn't really internalize before
first of all my grandpa who just went in
there like two days ago it's taking five
to seven days for him to get his tests
back mm-hmm I've heard about that five
to seven days from the guiness test back
and then the so the next other craziest
part is that nobody can go and visit it
nobody can go in there yeah that was the
first time I thought about it when the
guy we know said someone passed that he
knows from their family that made me
realize like if someone actually dies
that you know it's this is such a weird
time because they're gonna have to be
there alone
and the family can't even do a funeral
or you can't have a funeral mourn you
can't go to visit Lee you can't be by
their side like in Israel you did that
she
is you know the whole family sit
together for seven days I can't do that
either can't do that yeah that it's
really weird so this is kind of what
I've started to realize yeah how seeing
it in my own family now is that even if
you don't have the virus let's say it
takes five to seven days your ass is
stuck in there quarantine and you're
probably gonna have it by the time you
leave gospel anyway I don't think my
grandpa's gonna leave the hospital
unfortunately but the doctors are so
overrun you're not even getting
attention my mom's on the phone with him
and he's gasping for breath and she's
trying to call the hospital to get
doctors to go take care of him and and
they're also overloaded nobody can even
give him attention and it's to the point
where they look at him and say 94 year
old guy double pneumonia
he's definitely his chance at making it
through this is almost zero
so actually we we need to be smart what
do they call that when they have to have
to pick what do they call that it's
called a triage they have actual triage
going on where they have to select
people who have the best chance of
surviving they have this whole protocol
of being like okay so there's a
four-year-old here and the six-year-old
the 40 year old gets the ventilator
because he has more life to live and he
has a better chance of surviving that's
what's happening
my 94 year old grandpa's just sitting in
the hospital nobody can visit him nobody
there is interacting with him or cares
about him and and then and then when he
passes away nobody can even go to his
funeral
yeah and I'm actually now even more
concerned about the assisted living
facility he came out of because if it's
if there's grown virus inside the
assisted living center then there's
gonna be a lot of deaths and a lot of
the same [ __ ] going on that's the worst
place for I mean I remember when my dad
was at the hospital unrelated to a
crisis situation they're already
overworked it was already hard to get
attention for him or you know get the
proper yeah proper attention they're
busy and if something happens you gotta
go find someone and you gotta wait
because they have to do the whole floor
or whatever so just put
what's already a really tough situation
now in this crisis environment I can't
imagine what they go through in the
hospitals well it's it's Wars what
they're yeah right and the first
responders the frontline the nurses and
the doctors they don't have enough gear
they don't have they're reusing masks I
heard even a report that was telling
nurses that they'll be reprimanded if
they're using protective gear because
they don't have enough and then you save
it for the doctors can you imagine Isis
they don't even they're not even testing
now the frontline people they're
starting to die nurses and doctors on
frontline are dying and okay I can't
speak politically about this but I still
think that our government is not close
to even close to doing enough you know
there's a I mean just hearing talks
about like maybe lifting some of the
quarantine sounds so insane woman so he
first of all that's not gonna happen
because it would be so insane it's to do
it but what what it has an unintended
consequence of doing it what she's
signaling - right exactly
by saying that he's signaling to people
who are not taking it seriously that
it's okay to do that yeah and that's why
you see a lot of these churches and
community centers playing with the idea
of like yeah we're gonna be open yeah
we're gonna be open and you know they go
all these economists say are not
economists so it's really coming from
from look I'm just gonna say it's coming
from right wing news stations and
personalities they say the quote Dom
Trump you said let's not have the Cure
be worse than the sickness which is what
he's means is this whole lockdown is
hurting our economy so badly that it
might the more people can get hurt by
that than the actual virus which maybe
makes sense
Minh some way but you have to understand
that oh I forgot that's garlic nice oh
yeah
you have to understand that if people
the only way to fix the economy is to
kill the virus you cannot bring people
back to work and back into the community
because the virus is just gonna spread
and we're gonna end up in the same exact
situation we were the only way to fix
the economy is to defeat the virus the
minute that virus starts spreading again
we're all gonna go and lock down again
because people don't understand the
consequence of this is so catastrophic
that once you're presented with it the
horror of it you will crumble you will
crumble this week has gotten bad the
United States has became number one baby
yeah and coronavirus and by the way our
rate of double our rate of doubling is
two days there is no sign of its slowing
right now we have we have a lot of a lot
of pain and suffering here in the United
States still ahead of us unfortunately
so just stay strong stay indoors stay
quarantine we got to ride this out
there's no shortcuts here everyone
thinks there's the sadly there's just no
shortcuts here we got to ride it up do
you want to do our first sponsored by
coronavirus brought to you by the
coronavirus the USA number one in the
world it's kind of a bad time if I read
well when's a good time
what is expressvpn you guys what you my
online searches does the government have
a right to know about do they have a
right to know about my hentai habits you
know do they have a right to know about
what kind of pornography I watch at all
yeah
do they have a right to know that I've
watched too you remember two girls one
cup mm-hmm i watch that i watch that
basically a daily do they have a right
to know that I think they shouldn't have
with that if you watch it daily well
maybe if you alert them but
they should be able to spy on my
internet activity all right and that's
where expressvpn comes in the answer of
course is none of the above above but in
a god bless america
we always get it done and we believe in
freedom and protection and that's what
expressvpn is if you like owning a gun
then expressvpn is like owning a gun for
your internet privacy okay go age is P
your government
like that that cowboy without expressvpn
without express VPNs protection hackers
government ad companies and ISPs all
have full access to your data I don't
want them using my web history or video
game searches against me that's why I
use expressvpn every time I go in like
can you imagine the blackmail someone
could love me against me if they saw all
my internet search history you have
their unit search I mean I look at like
clothing websites and Amazon are closing
but do they ever maybe not very clothing
either so boring yeah the government
could spy on you but if you're like me
you have a lot to hide that's why I use
expressvpn every time I go online
expressvpn encrypts and reroutes your
web traffic to any number of countries
keeping you safer and secure simply
download the expressvpn app click to
connect and boom boom boom you're
protected with expressvpn you can make
it seem like you're browsing from a
different country so you can watch any
netflix library in the world you want
how cool is that I would have loved that
when I was back in Israel and all that
stuff yeah I didn't know about VPNs back
then but yeah we were in Israel for five
years of Netflix was like how all this
maze it called it and we couldn't watch
yeah expressvpn is the fastest VPN I've
ever tried it costs less than seven
dollars per month and it comes with a
30-day money-back guarantee it's time to
stop governments and Internet companies
from keeping tabs on your data
take back your online
privacy like I did with expressvpn
protect your online activity today and
find out how you can get three months
free at expressvpn comm /h 3 that's expr
ESS VPN comm / HD for three months free
with a one-year package visit expressvpn
comm / h3 how long was that that felt
won't I had done time it is that okay
for you guys where was I Kenneth
Copeland is a [ __ ] oh but there was a
really funny man I loved that everyone
was saying that it really looks like the
devil yeah just dots you died you know
the devil is a good Christian man it's
just saying I wanted to show you guys
this image from the subreddit where is
it
this is boring where is my dad where is
it was on the front page now that to me
was a picture of Kenneth Copeland next
to some goblin and he looked identically
there it is look at this look at this
it's crazy it's like the eyes is like he
does have those eyes I can't get over
their resemblance I feel like there is
something not human about this guy you
know we just watched outsider right yeah
good non Netflix actually say to me oh
oh HBO excuse me [ __ ] juice so that's
that yada yada yada so yeah be careful
out there guys now be careful and just
try to make the best of it you can still
go in a walk yes if you are like taking
it a little too crazy I think you can
still take your dog on a walk yes you
can take a walk just if you're gonna
walk just don't get near anybody right
six feet mm-hmm distance but it's good
to go outside you should go outside yes
don't go to a public Adam go by yourself
get some Sun I read a study that vitamin
D which you get from being in the Sun
help fortify your immune system against
respiratory diseases such as Koba 19 so
get some Sun but the good news is
basically there are people that are
doing something about this for example
gal gadot you guys probably heard about
this gal gadot and listed a bunch of
celebrities to sing imagine and they got
slammed right it's so cringy I mean it
really is so crazy let's just watch this
and then we can comment but hopefully
they're Beto shredders humping afraid of
nothing here hopefully there's bad
enough at singing this that we don't get
claimed it was like I think they summed
it bad enough okay I think that this
really let's watch Eunice I just feel
like looking at her now I feel like she
just knows how pretty she is and that
she's just like showing off how pretty
she is do you get that feeling I know a
minute I think she really thought she
was doing something cool probably you
know imagine how embarrassed they were
all these celebrities were once they
realize no stupid it is ahead let's go
you know this virus had affected the
entire world everyone doesn't matter who
you are you should have been superwoman
you know yours really you're tall and
beautiful
why aren't you super women why hurt I
can't do it why why hurt you wouldn't
made this video just saying I think
healers should be super women how tall
is she how tall is gal gadot damn look
that up we're gonna have than all the
guys starting next week we're gonna do a
zoom
zoom zoom zoom and we're gonna have them
all called in so they'll be able to
comment and bicker as we love he's
five-ten
well she's 510 your your that I thought
she was taller than that you might be
taller than she is or the same size
probably the same hold on the everyone's
fronting like she's so tall but that's
how tall you are I am tall for you no
I'm saying you're a Wonder Woman she's
[ __ ] she's a poser his balcony how
old is she look look that up I just saw
she started 4 she's older than you and
she's shorter than you she's not shorter
than me she probably is you're you are
superwoman
a Wonder Woman and not she's a
supermodel then she's the beauty queen
she's a beauty queen
yeah Oh for real you're a beauty queen
look at your shirt keep telling me
you're not superwoman
Wonder Woman whatever the [ __ ] she is
okay so she saw a musician playing
imagine because everyone in Italy were
singing and playing in their porches
right because so Italian it was really
cool maybe she's a he's a musician
playing it on a trumpet and so she's so
in her mind she goes well me singing it
would be as beautiful in power and then
she goes let me just enlist every all
the most famous people I know and
somehow yeah well let me watch I'm
getting ahead of myself
no heaven it's easy if you try no hell
was this guy and I was trying to
recognize this guy who is this guy
don't ask me was he um top what was he
an looks like it's face to non they're
all weird and blurry above us only sky
like they have no concept of what's
before after above us only sky like how
do I follow that up imagine all the
people I say it's pretty crazy for a
comedian to be involved in this I just
wonder how they were instructed what was
this because I feel like gal gadot may
be [ __ ] all these people by just
making it seem like it was just some fun
thing she was doing she was probably
like well we can't all sink together in
one room so let's make an edit where
each one sings our line I just I don't
even get it like it's okay almost
watching it's like - a tree line you
don't the flow imagine I don't know who
that guy and then everyone's trying to
show off what good singers they aren't
[ __ ] with the reliance damn it isn't
hard to do nothing to kill or die for
[Music]
that's not how it goes imagine all the
people like lady just trying to steal
the limelight you know what I mean like
damn all these celebrities and she's
trying to steal the one lip that's not
how the song goes
[Music]
Wow people are people are I guess
rightfully saying all these rich has
people in their homes talking about
imagine no posessions to that I do say
John Lennon was richer than all these
people that being said that's very
unsafe work but so what like they're
they're kind of admitting to themselves
that this celebrity first of all is like
the dumbest most pointless thing because
you end up worshipping these first of
all at least I'm going to say you don't
you gotta breathe for a second look what
I think is so stupid about celebrities
that you don't know anything about these
people yeah yeah you can worship me at
least you know a little bit more about
me worshipping me is fine but these
people who are on the silver screen you
don't know anything about them all you
know is that they pretend to be someone
else for two hours in a film worshiping
them you don't know anything about that
you know if they're smart if they're
educated if they're good at anything
without word if they're
shitty people and so the fact that they
think that they that their celebrity is
so this is so embarrassing my
overreacting a little bit I think so
embarrassing I think it's just stupid I
think they all thought they were doing
something nice but it's just so dumb I
think the situation is so dark right now
this is not doing anything good imagine
right just something so self-centered
about it
it's very disconnected too because a lot
of the people who are in the worst shape
are people who are can't afford to pay
the rent and have no job and [ __ ] and
well it's just funny I shouldn't get so
pissed off it's really just funny yeah
hold together Ethan now's not the time
keep it cool you're right
also I'm a celebrity is should I not I'm
not really a celebrity like they are am
i being a hypocrite right now I just I
don't think they're bad people
I don't think hey I didn't say that I
just said you don't know anything about
them right you don't but that's die you
should criticize the people worship them
but aren't they kind of accepting it by
doing this they're accepting their
celebrity status by by saying like me
singing imagine with all these other
famous people is beautiful like this
Italian man playing the trumpet and in
Italy it's it's just it's a little
unsafe work yeah yeah give me your best
line say imaginal no way singing like
they would imagine all the people not
ruin your day all right I'm not sure you
couldn't ruin anyone's day
[Music]
oh I have a feeling that she instructed
them to do it vertical on the phone and
make it look as home-home produced as
possible a lot of my like outside and
they're just like I've never even seen
phone footage of this shitty no she gets
to started end it I feel like I just
blame gal gadot for this one cuz she
started and ended it I wonder if anyone
with world Farrell was like yo how did I
get roped into this like such a stooge
that's true cuz they're all just
probably doing her a favor cuz yes
that's what it is if they're all doing
her a favor yeah girl you're supposed to
represent us well you can start down
your stepping up your young dollar a job
more beautiful everyone loves her yeah I
like the babies yeah I think you're more
attractive I think you're younger
oh I'm just saying you're superwoman
super Wonder Woman Wonder Woman I think
it is she's all I was just thinking that
you know I was just I've gotten all
philosophical sure hair is all perfect
alright by the way and she's the only
one with footage that's like semi good
everyone else looks old Haggard
alright gal get out of here gal get out
of here what else we got what time is it
I'm trying because we don't have it then
it's time for the read Dan you gotta
remind us honey
everybody loves honey imagine all the
honey save
you money you know that honey is the
free online shopping tool that
automatically finds the best promo codes
it applies them to your cart and you
know just how great it feels to save but
how does it feel to save with honey well
saving with honey
feels like sliding into a seat on the
train just before the doors closed this
joke doesn't work in this days yeah you
know it's like sliding right into the
subway it's like dude nobody wants to
slide into the subway right now let me
improv save them with honey
feels like pulling a tick finally off
Alfredo that was that girl week and
you're gonna let me touch it
how about that honey that's pretty good
yeah that's awful hitting every green
light on your commute that feels good
finishing your podcast up so right as
you walk into work right we need some
quarantine yeah Reed's for this it feels
good let me just tell you saving with
honey feels a great because you're about
to buy something it automatically
applies the coupon a checkout and boom
you just save ten fifteen twenty dollars
you didn't expect it feels like your
fridge just refilled itself with
groceries out of nowhere magic what's
your kind of it you're getting free
money right oh it's like it's like you
came home and your mom went shopping and
filled your gross or your wife in your
case yours was better you don't need to
fill in the blanks so much because magic
obviously nobody believes in magic
trying to give them more plausible is a
experience imagine all the people I love
honey I will always use honey til the
day I die or the internet is shut off
worldwide honey is a miracle it is magic
because you're just shopping yada yada
yada
you've all got this free browser plug-in
then you're buying something you usually
would and then ten dollars for free it's
that ridiculous
what do we buy something reside
from Levi's leave them stuff and it was
like Christie off or something we then
will add this creation data add the
screenshot but you're just shopping yeah
you've got the honey plugged in you
didn't expect to be saving any money
today on the Internet added what a
couple of jeans yeah you're at checkout
you're checking out your about to make
your purchase and then honey's like hold
on one second let me just go through my
coupon collection oh here you go save
$50 that's right we need that honey has
found it's over 18 million members it
has found it's over breathe all sentence
honey has found it's over 18 million
members over two billion dollars in
savings
whoa that's how many ventilators is that
two billion
did you know honey supports over 30,000
stores online including Macy's Target
Sephora Best Buy and more and they're
adding more each and every day users
love honey that's why it has over a
hundred thousand five-star reviews on
Google Chrome store using honey feels so
good think of it as a daily victory plus
it's free to use and installs in just
two seconds get honey for free at join
honey calm slash h3 that's join honey
calm slash h3 nice what else we got this
is so cool
as you know New York City is been hit
hard harder than anywhere in the world
it's becoming the epicenter of the kovat
19 and the New York City Health
Department has issued a sex and corona
virus disease update giving advice to
New Yorkers on how to keep themselves
protected when it comes to sexual
encounters so let me read that for you
this name they're really thorough yeah I
mean whatever you can do helps you know
all New Yorkers should stay home and
minimize contact with others but can you
have sex here are some tips to enjoy sex
and avoid spreading covet 19 know how
Cove at night can I just say Cove in
nineteen it sucks the name it sucks that
they should have got a way better name
like SARS MERS swine flu h1z1 those
sounds so sick kovat 19 is the worst
name
ever that's a really great deal it's
blocking my chakra I've been trying to
get creative about like staying at home
and having to be at home and just do
more creative stuff and I'm like you
think it's the name I'm blocked yeah I
think it's the Cova can I tell you
something I think that had a better name
people would be taking it more seriously
hmm if it had a name like h1z1 right
more like that's why I blue or SARS is a
great acronym people are not taking this
coat it's like Jose coronavirus is a
kovat 19 oh there's other coronaviruses
that aren't a big nope we have to call
it like murder/death/kill
m DK m DK that's 69 no covin 19 I'm
serious whoever thought that name up
really dropped the ball I don't like it
I don't like it I don't like it
I mean covet let me try to think of one
I can't think of one right so know how
covet 19 spreads you can get Cova 19
from a person who has it the virus can
spread to people who are within six feet
of a person through coughs or sneezing
Minh Tran Spurs through saliva or mucus
we still have a lot to learn about kovin
19 and sex kovat 19 has been found in
feces of people who are infected with
the virus Gila Cova 19 has not yet been
found in semen or vaginal fluid hmm okay
that's good to know we know that other
corona viruses do not efficiently
transmit through sex having sex with
people close to you you are your safest
sex partner ELA masturbation will not
spread over 19 no how would I why would
you even do that
what are you going you're like you're
just gonna like manifest it into
existence through masturbating
especially if you wash your hands and
any sex toys with soap and water for at
least 20 seconds before and after sex
the next safest partner is someone you
live with having close contact having
sex with only small circle
people while they're really giving
people a lot of credit a small circle of
people how many people is that I'm
surprised how detailed this like five
they're saying I can [ __ ] five people
what's a small circle it's awesome it's
also like the next safest partner
someone you live with so they're almost
being like well obviously we're married
but it's like oh well if you have a
roommate they're fine too but we weren't
sexually active but we're all holed up
you should avoid close contact including
sex with anyone outside your household
if you do have sex with others have as
few partners as possible and avoid group
sex now is not the time for orgy in New
York if you usually meet your sex
partner online or make a living by
having sex consider taking a break from
in-person dates or video dates sexting
sexting oh they say video dates and
sexting is a good option for you mm-hmm
take care during sex kissing can easily
pass covin 19 no kissing avoid kissing
anyone who is not part of your smart
small circle of close contacts I love
that in this bulletin it sounds like
everybody is like has five partners it's
awesome it's like you have this three
guys that you're cool with mmm so you're
okay with oh and then you have to
interrogate them like look I need to
know how many people are in your circle
all right my circle there's five learn
your circle here's my favorite part
kissing no good oh here they go they say
[ __ ] yeah and then in parentheses
outward it says Remmy right here look it
says [ __ ] straight up Wow
it says [ __ ] mouth to anus appendices
might spread Koba 19 biros and feces may
enter your mouth
no really do the people they're
addressing always how do you tell this
is well this is health
you got a I'm so surprised you got it
like it is to prevent well read of this
deadly virus
no [ __ ] ela well you can rip me we're
in close quarters you're in my circle
yeah you're my sister don't rim
strangers at this time you guys although
they say no [ __ ] straight up right
but they say I can kiss you like
anything so you could kiss people in
your circle so I can't remember if you
can kiss me you can rim me that's the
rule can you kiss then rim or in Bank
kiss I mean that's how growth you are
right that's non related today yes I
just curious condoms can reduce contact
especially during anal sex they're very
few possess you washing up before and
after sex is more important than ever or
and after washing up before and after
sex yeah it's more important than ever
they're like you should have already
been doing that you sick [ __ ] but now
you really should
so no [ __ ] is the big takeaway here
guys no dreaming I gotta tell you I was
trying to rim me the other day like no
no no no this is bringing me to cool
more or how do you say his last name
Cuomo Cuomo the governor yeah of New
York yeah is this related to him do you
think so it's one of his initiative well
it's a New York City thing is probably
more of mayor de Blasio's oh okay
who's the mayor of New York City gotcha
okay I've been seeing him a lot
oh wait no lately wait hold on this was
a New York oh yes see this is New York
City so yeah that's the Blasio if it's
New York could be Cuomo anyway I've been
saying Cuomo a lot lately in the news
yeah he's taking like the lead I don't
know if it's just his city's hit the
hardest
yeah he's trying to help his people and
you know it's funny I look at the I look
at Governor Cuomo when he does his press
releases he sit he's in a big warehouse
he's sitting at a podium and all of the
people in the audience does not many are
all 6 feet apart so you have like
row of like three seats really spread
and it goes back and he's in the front
nobody's near each other when the White
House gives a press conference you've
got like 20 people shoulder to shoulder
and I'm thinking to myself this looks so
stupid you are you're sending such I
it's so stupid why do you guys cuddle
around you're telling the whole country
to social distance six feet but when you
do your own press conference every day
you guys are shoulder to shoulder it
doesn't make any sense do you want us
huddled or not if you don't want to
huddle you need to set an example and
step the [ __ ] away from each other it
says it's stupid what else we got oh we
have some field reports oh so the Philly
offensive you guys may remember he was
interviewed by us somewhat recently he
was making these unbelievable sketches
we didn't know if they're real or fake
it turns out they were staged we got him
on a call and said you know what we need
you on the on the field making videos
for us and he did them here also Ethan
Bradberry who were trying to get as a
field reporter went out into New York
City to interview people about the
corona virus let me tell you this not
only can I not show you the video
I'm pretty sure if I did show you the
video I made they Ethan Bradberry would
be going to jail Stiles terror it's that
bad I mean it's a shame cuz it's it's
funny but at the same time it's so
irresponsible and it's just so wild that
we could not endorse and I can't I the
whole time I was watching it I was just
like what is wrong you know what [ __ ]
what is wrong with you so I can't show
it but I wish I could but I really
should not fair I really should it and
eat my message to Ethan Bradberry is
this cuz there's certain parts where
he's just there talking to people and
it's so funny just you don't have to I
don't need all this crazy stick like
he's pretending he had coronavirus like
he would be talking to them and now
was funny he was asking what you think
coronavirus and then he would start
acting like he had grown advice and
start coughing and then he was like I
have it and so that's where it went too
far yeah if you're just interviewing
people if that's still funny because
Ethan Bradberry is funny but he was not
keeping the six fit no part so I don't
know when you recorded this there was a
lot of people in the street so I'm not
gonna throw him totally under the bus
there yeah he is going to redo it is it
going to redo it
I would love 50 readers so I would
suggest that he follows the rules follow
the socials and don't but Nia don't tell
me but you know there's people who are
going to jail right now for coughing on
people for felony charge really yeah you
can't do that Wow
you can't do it that's good yeah imagine
you're infected and you're going off on
some money yeah do you have a 2% chance
of dying oh yeah I wouldn't want to roll
the dice on 2% I just didn't know they
were doing that but that's good yeah
I've read a couple articles like that so
my message to Ethan is if you want to
redo it I would love to see a man on the
street - interviewing people about
corona but and just being a flower
business just be yourself
right don't ya do what you don't have to
you don't have to say I have coronavirus
do you Nathan Bradbury love Ethan
Bradberry Ethan Bradberry we love he
would be like they must've been flying
summer because they were in the airport
[ __ ] with people there and he would
go up to somebody with who's with his
family and he's like hey do you know
where uh you know where the the taxi
line is and you could imagine he's
driving people crazy and these were not
fake no they were not saying I assure
you these were not fake he goes to this
taxi driver this tacky taxi drivers pull
he's got a huge taxi man and Ethan
Bradberry goes can I get him front and
the guys like sitting back why we just
want to sit in front he's like I want to
sit in front
is it getting back and Ethan those and
then he's like okay okay okay so he
moves all the stuff and
sits in the front seat and he goes I'm
reporting from regular Raw central what
do you think about the coronavirus I
have it so he essentially pressured this
taxi guy to let him sit in front oh man
knock a shame on you through Bradbury
but remake it the good way I can't show
this both of us will be crucified you
shouldn't have done that
that being said Phil offensive let's
watch what Philly offensive did this is
a h3 podcast exclusive the Philly
offensive interviewing people on the
streets hmm excitement is in the air
what's wrong what's going on man you
care if I ask you a couple questions are
you worried about the coronavirus and do
you think it's real or what I love these
extras thank you serious $5 he hit you
yo did the you-know-whats helper I think
that's him gets all these people these
people are legends yeah
yeah definitely did you shoot yourself
well he's got one leg but you found it
deal with one leg to pretend he [ __ ]
himself guy is the this looks so legit
hold on if I didn't know that this was
all sketch I would just be loving this
like I would be eating it up he's so
good I definitely did see this guy's
this is a social distance critic so you
don't you don't think it's [ __ ] at
all what is going on yeah and a full
hazmat suit really got it sound like
it's the subtle touches get me and then
just cutting it right there is you a
quick question what do you think about
the corona Byers you worried wait what
what just happened oh my god do you
think about the corona Byers you worried
oh my god oh my god I watched another
version of this and it wasn't in here
really he just added the scene I got
appreciate the fact that they did
project what are you worried about the
crowbars what do you think about it
obviously you're worried are you worried
that it's going to spread all over
Philly are you worried it's gonna spread
over Philly ruling this right Alfredo
kill shredder
okay shredders I'm King Alfredo great
whatever a virus yeah cigarette no I
don't smoke could you give us your
opinion on the corona virus I can't get
a virus okay okay good age twice
actually what you think about the corona
virus and what's going on the Philly
[ __ ] swallow what do you think of
ours bro
[Music]
I get the feeling he doesn't think much
about
philadelphians this is what he foresees
the people of Philadelphia I really feel
like this guy needs his own show
there's something brilliant about that
car crash it was so fantastic I just I
can't believe you find so many people to
like that's a lot of people to get to
cooperate with you did he convince
someone to crash a car into a wall no I
gotta go back and watch that one more
time yeah this was amazing you don't you
don't think it's [ __ ] at all what do
you think about the coronavirus you
worried dude
well the Philly offensive alleys and
gentlemen Wow Wow incredible right
shredder he's got a knack whoa whoa I
don't know we got to send him out on the
street to report on something else I
think he shot this before things got
even more crazy with the quarantine yeah
yeah yeah yeah well we gave him this
assignment a wild oh yeah this is
clearly a masterpiece you've been laying
the groundwork on wow I can't believe
you crashed a car for us I'm actually
really happy that we didn't know that
yes we got the real surprise here Wow
the Philly offensive laser Jimmy can
find him on Facebook and YouTube he is
now an official correspondent he's hired
officially I mean I we need like a new
virus or something to send him out to
we're going to well we'll think about it
we have a sponsor here by me undies who
makes the softest most fun undies known
to man whether you like crazy fun prints
or opt for black classic black me undies
gives you the freedom to express
yourself comfortably keep your distance
oh come on is in six you rim me you
already won our car
I did not you could you're in my circle
me undies it's flexible is breathable
it's soft its stretchy if you're a fat
guy like me you need a little extra
girth a little extra stretch on certain
occasions this is the perfect underwear
for you it's awesome mandis has plenty
of option for those looking to up their
undie game you can join the monthly
subscription membership build a pack
selecting a matching pair to match with
your better half do they have a [ __ ]
themed cycle with a hole for the bottle
will that be for you or just pick out
one pair that strikes your fancy
they're pretty laid-back so go ahead and
do what you want who's laid-back me on
these are the underwear that's a good
question they're laid-back me undies is
pretty laid-back so it's all good do
whatever you want
mandis are made with soft sustainable
fabric mandis doesn't just make undies
they also have a loungewear which
recently had a glow-up check out their
new line of micro modal loungewear you
can wear in and out of the house now by
the way they're on doors made of this
thing micro modal which actually is this
unbelievable
soft breathable fabric that was
discovered in walk Wanda is that the
Black Panther well Conda is a mythical
fabric it's so good
mandis has a great offer for my
listeners for any first-time purchasers
you get 15% off and free shipping also
is a no-brainer considering they have a
100% satisfaction guaranteed that's how
you know they are convinced that they're
soft and pretty little underwear will
send you to the moon and back
get your 50% off your first order free
shipping and 100% satisfaction
guaranteed go to me on DS comp slash
atria that's me on DS comm slash h3
[Music]
[Music]
that's it that's our last sponsor yes
I'm curious if that if this format of
like boom-boom-boom is better because
sometimes we do a sponsor break three at
a time or more sometimes also the
difference is that normally we can edit
and put them together mm-hmm but this is
they're probably taking longer the way
we're doing it right now so three in a
row like this would take forever be like
ten minutes to nobody yeah you know try
to keep it interesting for me and ease
oh soft breathable underwear sometimes I
just like to you know I might even go
there they're gonna they're gonna make
me do another one I go there half life
oh you guys I got it I got I really have
to vent you guys been following The
Bachelor Trisha Paytas was our next
Bachelorette and I gotta take a swig of
water
okay so Trisha Paytas as you guys know
the first season of The Bachelor with
Ian are our salaried employee he met
somebody in the DMS and he's now I'm
happy to report he's in a faithful
relationship with her which I'm very
happy about but there was a lot of drama
because he basically ruined the show we
were never able to have the show go to
fruition because he was already in love
with this girl in the DMS I was like
well what's the point of even continuing
right he wouldn't let her come on the
show you wouldn't let us talk to her so
I was like okay you ruined it so now
fast-forward to Trisha Paytas now your
brother we went through the first two
rounds we saw a bunch of videos that
people do wanted to be with Trisha and
we told her that if someone reaches out
in the DM just let us know just keep us
in the loop he says look the first
season was ruined yeah lack of integrity
in the system I'm not going to tell you
what to do but if you have a
back-channel conversation
you have to disclose that to us yes you
have to tell us and we need to bring
them on the show I don't want another
wildcard situation and then we have your
brother who was going to be the bachelor
before Trisha Paytas mm-hm and and I
told him the same thing I said if you're
gonna be involved no shenanigans no wild
card no damn no [ __ ] you have to
tell us everything and he swore he said
it's all about the show about making the
show better and so last time
Trisha goes at the end you know I was
really hoping that Moses ILA's brother
was going to apply it okay okay and we
said yeah we thought he was too because
he mentioned to us he wanted to do it as
a goof that's what I thought if I'm
being honest just to spice up this [ __ ]
right but now they've been talking in
the dams apparently because Trisha in
the last episode was like I really
thought he was going to apply I like him
okay so now I find out that they've been
talking in the DMS on Instagram and that
they've been well actually the real the
real thing that shocked me and first of
all I have to show that I mean he don't
know anything about this no nobody's
telling us any well okay so after the
episode ended with her let me show this
manager either he watches this we saw
this on Twitter wait wait no he told us
that after the end of the show it's all
listed they spoke in the DM right he did
say that yeah yeah but then that was it
and we're like okay just you know you
gotta tell us what's happening and we
got a we can't have another one of those
situations yeah and he was like yes of
course course he says so that was our
last update that's all right now
Alfredo's got a he's got a cherry eye
which is a prolapse of the tear gland
and we're trying super hard to take good
care of it because he's got to get a
surgery yeah I'm
in the story but this is employer and
now shredder and shredder is now
slicking it so once you tell sure I
don't do not do something it just
becomes obsessed with doing it you can
snip that yes it's fine if there's a
jump cut I don't care yeah or actually
you can just do a full-screen of the
photo okay so I was saying that the last
thing when you write was that they made
a contact in the DMS that was it
yes then I think what happened was that
we had a power outage for a full day
here during quarantine by the way and it
was raining outside so was that the
worst were the worst we were quarantine
we had no power no reception no internet
and raining and raining we're literally
just in an hour it was just it was just
dark and I literally just slept out of
boredom you ever just slept cuz you're
so bored anyway anyway next day then it
comes back up we open our phones open
Twitter and this is what we see no no
nobody message us your brother first of
all I have to say I have to tell you
that I don't know what he's up to right
and I know it isn't some inside joke but
look at the way he's looking at so this
is what Trisha posted look at his face
what is he doing is it's like he's he's
like he's goofing on us like look well
it's hard to tell I slice by the way for
Trisha nice feel you can't tell could be
just ham smiling bro what are you doing
what are you doing you know what's my
biggest fear right now is that this
actually becomes serious because Trisha
kept trying to come over to our house
and babysit Theodore it's not happening
is that she's gonna end up finding a way
to come over to our house but she's
Moses's girlfriend no she's not allowed
over Oh
so this isn't even the worst of it and
by the way I got well obviously I
immediately go to Moses and I'm like
dude what's what the f is this
and he's so cryptic now all the sudden
he's not telling me what's up yeah he's
being super cryptic and like he goes oh
yeah we hung out a few times and I go
out and I keep pressed and he will not
give it up so both of these people
promised me to keep the bit 100 billion
with me yes they promise like I'm most
disappointing your brother Trisha
whatever you wish you know we serve at
her pleasure I mean you don't know which
work which personality is showing up
towards day I'm just happy when she
comes in I mean I expected her to to
work within the guidelines to your
brother those on our side and now I
don't know whose side he's on right well
it gets worse there's more we are see
these on her Instagram stories in bed
with somebody yeah and and we see a hand
and I'm like again a cryptic I think
that's his I think it's his arm it looks
good
it definitely is but the evidence piles
on as we continue forth here she posts
pictures of she says quarantine date
night okay now okay so let's just say
okay this is a separate day so whoever
this is has come back to her house a
date night she calls it a date night and
whoever it is brought dinner which by
the way looks like quite a fancy dinner
too if I'm being fun being honest that
looks good I'm very hungry go ahead you
want to talk about your discovery yes
now Ethan put this in our document with
like question mark not knowing if it's
my brother well I know my brother and I
immediately spotted his stickers on the
table he does artwork with water and he
has stickers that he always will give
people and I have those stickers myself
and I know those stickers when I see it
that's
my brother oh those are definitely his
stickers well at first I was looking at
his hand I was like is that Moses right
the stickers that's it he has a big role
I know about this role he has a huge
role of stickers of his water heart and
that's that's off his role so he's
hanging out with her now more not
telling us I'm like it what's going on
with Trisha downplaying it but thou here
we go
so I even wonder if you put it there on
purpose and that's what I was wondering
right now - but I don't think so because
first of all the shows on hiatus
nobody knows what's the depth of this
Bachelorette ya know so what exactly is
he playing - also I don't think the
Trisha Trisha
is she started she's not coven I think
she just wants to [ __ ] Moses so as Moses
playing Trisha and us mm-hmm and some
weird what's what's he trying to get at
I think he likes her and he won't admit
it I think your brother actually likes
her and he's embarrassed to admit it
which is fine by the way I was like look
me neither we're talking about this
because we're just so perplexed by it
and we go look a lot of reputable
successful seemingly normal people have
dated Trisha so well she's not my type
but clearly a lot of guys like to would
like to date her
yes and so I think your brother is
embarrassed to admit that he actually I
don't know why he's embarrassed if
that's the case well if we're if they
are dating or whatever she's gonna be
pissed when she watches this so the
truth is gonna come out getting back
Moses Moses why are you embarrassed why
don't you tell them that we're dating
and so now Moses about to meet one of
her nasty personalities they didn't get
yet I will sabotage this relationship I
don't give a [ __ ] because you both
[ __ ] us
so then just yesterday she tweets in
Hebrew yeah what what is that supposed
to mean what does it say you Oh wah wah
wah it means my love - but you would say
to me cuz it's like addressing a female
right so if you wanted to
my love to me you would say oh but they
the Americans understand gendered so she
are meant to write it from my brother
and she made a mistake on gender or she
definitely meant it for your brother why
all the sudden she's reading Hebrew
another way you could use it is to say
loved oh I don't think she did she's
obviously trying to say she loves your
brother in Hebrew there's no other
explanation but then this is the final
straw for me this happened around the
same time the same day she says I don't
know if I'm in love or just bomb-ass
dick so I have to ask you it you'll at
this point I feel like I feel like that
one especially I think she's doing it to
me on purpose you think so because why
you have to say that well that's Trisha
she always say [ __ ] like that I don't
want to hear that I don't want to hear
it either it's horrifying so how do you
feel about your brother having
apparently bomb-ass dick I don't want I
don't
nothing let's [ __ ] it done I hate it I
hate everything about it but it does
start by the way Moses if you go back to
the first photo where Moses is grinning
it on hold in authority he's the one
holding the phone he is complicit in all
of this so you start here you go all the
way down to tweeting he has bomb-ass
dick on Twitter he's complicit in all of
it he can't ever say this ran away from
him because he took this photo I don't
know I don't know Joe is off I'm
cancelling the Bachelorette is over we
have this is not even a Walter not fair
for the people who applied I'm actually
it's totally unfair its outrages and let
me just say that as a host I'm
disappointed this will never happen
the bachelor is over its curtain so
cursed well at least you know Indians
case you did get your love right
something beautiful this is office is a
beautiful is awful
in this case our life is right what
about Moses let me ask you what about
the story about someone I don't want to
mean her work but what about her
appearances on her show made you want to
date her
I think I don't think I could see I mean
I guess everybody probably first of all
a lot of people would be attracted to
examine third type thicker than a
snicker as they say right with some
bolted on titties to boot see this is
outrageous because I've seen her do you
understand Moses that the girl you're
apparently dating has sent me personally
me tweeted at me pictures of her vagina
right do you understand what you're
doing that's a problem do you undo even
understand she the girl that you're
apparently dating what you think is
funny I wanted to have a throuple with
your slider and your brother-in-law true
do you understand what your problem if I
ever saw one she had double chlamydia
Moses at one point just saying she does
have a very interesting background her
stories are very interesting I just want
to say that's not a question I'm just
upset I may be I'm saying I'm being read
I'm upset because I've grown to like
Trisha quiet me - which is why I'm even
more upset because I wanted to I don't
like to work out this I don't like I
don't like it I'm sitting now I really
want to send their ass on a cruise I
don't know what to make of this I really
don't so it's that cancelled I guess
we're just gonna have to get them both
on a call we're gonna have to maybe on
zum-zum I don't know if this call we
should do on soon we're gonna have to
get them and just good we're gonna have
to debrief this but I don't think we can
ever do the bachelor again no it's just
curse it's cursed
yeah the first of the bachelor is real
and it's affecting us personally I think
this is only the beginning it then you
think this is only the beginning get
work
because I don't know yet dis evaluate
sure of this relationship well i disavow
it and please stop posting why do you
have to post pictures on Twitter just
keep it private dude I know you [ __ ]
people privately Trisha qui can't this
be private well you have to post
pictures of Eva's brother on Twitter I
don't get that need to be social about
it right I'm kind of glad that where
this is happening during quarantine time
cuz I wasn't gonna see my brother anyway
for a little while after this because
we're in quarantine anyway because I
don't know how to handle it yet yeah we
need some time we're gonna need some
time and you know he said he was just
gonna get involved as a goof but now all
the sudden there's no goof and he's just
[ __ ] her every day and they're
tweeting about it I don't need that [ __ ]
my life bro just showing up with my
timeline all right let's get out let's
get off this but Trisha and ruined it
was a Trisha or Moses
I personally blame Moses I just think
could sink repent for it a throuple
effort yes well cuz she's the one who's
she keeps pushing it with those tweets
to she and I think she knows those
tweets are gonna get us
I think Moses is putting her up to it
too I think they think it's funny maybe
who knows but if they didn't [ __ ]
there's almost zero percent chance they
didn't [ __ ] yeah I don't cuz no doesn't
there's based on what she's saying and
posting but also she said on the podcast
that if she's hanging out with a guy
she'll [ __ ] them like they're just my
question just a hundred percent right
should say that all evidence is pointing
that it did happen I got more but I feel
like ending it
let's see big arrow let me just end on
some gifts
big knife smoke could someone explain me
what the hell is wrong with dr. Phil he
tweets out big knife small wife either
unpack that for me
with her taking a big-ass bite of God
knows what go ahead and unpack that
would you I feel like it's kind of funny
which is disturbing me because I don't
want to believe that dr. Phil is funny
like I wanna I want to look at this and
say this is creepy but big knife small
wife is kind of like a reference to his
penis right is it I think that's what
the first thing I thought of was like
big big small wife cuz weapon is
unsheathed or what does it mean he's
gonna kill her easily with the knife
yeah that's what I thought yeah and his
maniacal smile dr. Phil's on another
level bro but I see someone said I can't
solve this is sexual or threatening
alright but it's kind of funny isn't it
yes of course it is but it's just still
surprising it's not a joke I would think
to make spreads dr. Phil but there's a
third person here with it taking a
picture who's the third person
what is she taking a bite of it's okay
how could you possibly what is it
nice kitchen mm-hmm really nice kitchen
what's this circle era is this like a
serving mmm circle dr. Phil you don't
good for yourself buddy
big nice small wife news report gone
wrong this is pretty fine so this dude
is doing a news report and bite you know
what a bison is they're these crazy
looking I think you've told me
previously that you have like a phobia
of bison I think so I don't let these
crazy mother-effing yeah Buffalo bison
huge yeah look at this they just
actually look at that look scary oh yeah
they look horrified they'll mess you up
this thing's way like a thousand pounds
probably so this guy's doing and on the
field reporting and a bunch of Isis
roaming threads in March up three Oh
oh my god oh no I'm messing with you I
think this is live streams various trunk
I'm surprising the pack of that that's
awesome so this is apparently what he I
think one would just started walking
towards him it's awesome this is him
Dion Boxton legend so that's a little
goof for you all to enjoy Dan sent me
this great news for Dan specifically if
you want to call and you're joined in
the meeting and now somebody's starting
to eat some chips opening the chip bags
you can hear a lot of background noise
and it's very hard to understand me very
clearly teams can remove that background
noise and you can understand me very
clearly so how about this how about just
don't eat chips during a call well you
would think that but then apparently
cannot see I understand that even during
a show also like is this the best
application of AI like is this this
guy's life work to take out the audio
from the fuel on the coal baggage at the
meeting so outraged that very clearly no
just put the chips down during for the
call cheese in the same bag that yeah
yep it's the kettle the kettles so
that's for a good news for Dan are you
gonna be able to get your hands on that
AI noise-canceling technology down if
not you're gonna have to not eat chips
during the show I have skipping with the
cans but maybe I'll save this for next
week it was kind of long Skippy the
Virgen went to Cannes
Film Festival and he blitz a bunch of
celebrities and it gets them to give us
the HD podcast a shout-out it's awesome
boy watch that next week so I actually
start editing our video so that's it
thank you all for watching stay safe
actually no response
right imagine can you imagine me like
taking a walk like I should go outside
and get like a long shot of our house I
need to stand in the most expensive
thing I own and talk about imagine no
posessions
mmm-hmm let me put it in that terms
imagine no posessions you're not gonna
sing a verse not living today
yeah alright let's wrap it up thank you
guys for watching I appreciate it
thank you for watching we'll be back
next week the show must go on
Tricia ruined the podcast Shep Moses
ruined the pocket that's right your
brother has good dick according to
Trisha kind of I don't want to ever know
that that was not appropriate does he
have a good day just weird
do I have good there
[Music]